一つめちゃくちゃ疑問に思ったことがありましていっ
一つ目指した技もハンドソープ
こういう怒らハンドソープなんですけどもうそんな時期なハンドソープって一回押し
たら泡が出るんですけども大勢姉書いてないんですよ帰っている量は書いてるんです
けど果たし何罪ポンプ何回ポンプ押すことができるかというかえてないんだよねわから
ないけどねこれ一個かんって何日間も柄とかどれくらいに変えたらいいのかというのは
ちょっとわかんないんだよ
今回はこちらの4種類の効果ハンドそっと準備しって果たしてこういう2つは何回今
プッシュすることができるのかっていうのを今回検証していこうと思いますこれ何か
わかること言いますとこれ4つあってもさんどれが何か一からこれで腕冬わかんない
それは館内この4つが何回ポンプすることができるかっていうのを調べる君によって
どれを買えば一番長持ちするかというのが分かります活気
いいでしょこれで一番多くてきたやつを買えば長持ちするかマジれないちょっと
もったいないかもしれないですけど高精度わかんないからコースないともう誰が誰だか
誰か誰か分かりますこうしないでも誰だけどなんか結ぶってのわかんないんだ今日は
坂路4 pop して果たして誰が一番音がもしするくらい一番ポップできるか知られ
いこうと思いますかもよページ入場料れのハンドソープ
これも結構人気というは有名ですよね250ml 入っていますマツモトキヨシで買っ
たハンドソープあんまり見たことないんですけど300ミリリットルヘック一番多い
この絵が結構好きですきれい機でキレイキレイも結構十数ですよね胃液姉があり
150ml
入ってます最後こちらフィンガーが書いてありますもう芝は脂肪は脂肪
ああああああああ
o 2ハード at ベロリッターこれが300mm 280250250これいう所
一番多いのは優勝すると思うんですけどもわかんない家本舗がどれぐらいそのなどほぼ
吸い上げる金ってまだ戦いが変わってくるんでや図っていこうと思いますまずは日和
からいきます
いまだノーカウントで出てからカウントしますからねブーブー
に結構出るなぁさあ
すずろ崩しチックっ9-9あきってどうぞ
場所今日
[音楽]
設計者地下99200200はいけますね
1 p えっさーちいっ
ana 機
301 e 300人 rc 染め2
と定める16パンネクスティ食べるとたチョア
もうこれダメだなぁ版びゃくにぐらいデー
[音楽]
断尾約20ということは1日1 push 使ったとしても11か月弱ぐらいは持つ
くらいな感じです次はこちらきれい機で行ってみましょうあのに同じなんで320回
超えるか超えないから勝負になってくると思います
月6粒に
[音楽]
2て事故で白く受け皿の救助がつっ k 塾ひっ
1981099200にやっていきました202203入居は205
888990はっはっは
ゆずツアーディズニーアークさぁ通常90某
90なあー聞け7パー98アーサー
刑事系300三十 p っ300にー
スパゲッティサーモン出てないしねこれは303かーいっ
何百3回か多いのが少ないかわかんないただ br が4が出ることが分かりました泡
ので行っちょいが強かったのでその分ために体力使うタイプだなぁとウォッシュバーン
てやって使ってみようと思いますこれ280なんでこの2つありが30ml 多い来て
のが食べ300体格今日がします12さんっ
ん
[拍手]
すっ敵前グッズを拝見する限り知り合いがやってきた患者で8月
[音楽]
993 u 99次号もう苦しいか
314ああああ苦しいダメで15
316哀悼えええええええ
やっぱり50本30016階でございます思ったより少ないか
なんか持つてみたいなちょっと前燃料多いのにあんまり変わんなかったですね相手月木
が本命ですマツモトキヨシの泡ハンドソーランヨーヨー的には一番多いですねこれが
300ミリリットルよねこれも400件以来かね駄目でしょ
さっそくやっていこうと思いますいぐわぁ
いきなり出るのね
研究所2000付いちゃっけいやガーゼっ200円234人
救急車に日系じゃんべき事項に f 97 a 9 dc 298299になってつ
違う
300円サービス an 23日1
考えちゃうな
浅間不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不不不不不不不不不不不
チェーン a でシャー
[音楽]
me
うううう
ああああああ
car
me
ちょっともったいないに再利用しようなんてこれで今日からだろうからこれできるから
だらを
ちょっと真面目それこそうーんまあ
まあなんか
まぁちょっとあっあっもうちょっとシリーズ